please welcome kelly marie tran
[Applause]
hi oh my gosh i am such a fan of you i'm
so excited to be talking to you
my daughters and i are freaking out that
you're here
um and there was so many things i
couldn't wait to discuss with you
i loved how you talked about that raya
is a warrior and not just a princess
and i did a film called ever after that
was like a spin on cinderella
because we need to be told not to wait
to be rescued
but to rescue ourselves and maybe even
others while we're at it
so what spoke to you about
getting to be disney's new
uh first southeast asian warrior
princess
i'm just so excited to be part of a
movie like you said that's sort of
broadening the narrative when it comes
to
what do people think when they think of
the word princess what do people think
when they think of the word hero
and recognizing that i think had a very
narrow perception of what those words
mean
and now to be sort of part of that
change and recognizing that raya like
you said you know is a character who
very much saves
herself and also is working to save a
lot of the people around her i think
that is
really important and uh it's really cool
to be a part of
i also know that you are the first
asian woman to be in these star wars
movies
talk about history we all grew up on
star wars and you're the first
i suppose it should have been earlier
but thank you for being
the first gosh star wars is such like a
big thing for so many people
and to have been a part of that really
meant a lot to me and i think
um you know we've talked a lot about
what it means to be the first
fill in the blank all of the time and i
think for me it's really
exciting to be a part of but also uh
recognizing that i i hope that i'm not
the last to be able to do these
you were also a first on the cover of
vanity fair for star wars you are
breaking so many
important glass ceilings and paving the
way
for others and i understand that mulan
um disney's first asian princess also
a staple in my household i've seen it a
billion
times and we love it that that was
something
um that was an inspiration to you
yeah that was such a huge part of my
childhood i think i was
nine when that movie came out and it was
the first time i
felt like i saw someone who looked like
me living in these sort of spaces
on that sort of scale um and mignolet
who plays
mulan is such an inspiration to me and
um
i actually got to meet her at the
episode 9 premiere and
she's such a symbol of all the things
that i i want to be um
such a such a cool experience well um
ming na
are you there hello
[Applause]
oh
oh my gosh how are you doing
i'm doing great congratulations on
everything
i feel like i'm looking in a mirror like
at the younger
because i followed kelly's footsteps
and became part of the star wars family
and now she's
follow you know my footsteps in being a
disney princess i just feel like we have
this whole mirror thing going on and i
love it
and i'm i'm so proud of you
and i'm also a geek so you're going to
have to sign my doll
yeah i love
that these are collectibles for a reason
because they are symbols
i mean we're talking about disney
princesses you are mulan
and raya these are the faces
the embodiments the voices and the
realization
of people seeing themselves in you
both and kelly i know
that you actually got off social media
because you were having a hard time
during star wars because
people felt in the cyber world um
you know entitled and enabled to say
things that
were not kind i would love to ask you
guys
in the face of what everybody is going
through
right now in the asian community do you
have any advice out there
for any girl woman or any age in between
who might be watching this
of how to find their superhero strength
in this time
right now it's you know it i i think
what drew was asking about
the anti-asian you know
hate that's out there i mean asian hate
out there
is i have a daughter who's
20 and she's going to college in new
york
and as a mother it's a great fear it's
it's a constant fear
um and it it kind of boggles my mind a
little bit that
it's happening still um
so i really hope your film raya you know
as
as mulan has done it crosses all
barriers it's about
finding the hero and the heroine in all
of us
it's about believing in yourself and
it's also about having compassion and
sharing
um the love to fight for
humanity and and fight for what's right
so you know all those messages is is
really really important and i think ray
is going to provide that for the new
generation
i'm i'm very grateful for that and thank
you drew for asking that question
it's a very serious question and i i
don't i'm i'm just also geeking out a
little bit about you drew
oh my gosh given us so much i mean
seriously your career talk about
storytelling and offering so much joy
and entertainment as well as um
just you know you're my idol
you're you're me so much
i just want all girls to believe
that uh that we are equal and that we
have
all the strength and capabilities
and possibilities so i honor the women
who uh prove that narrative to be true
such as yourself so thank you so much
for being here today
thank you all right
also in honor of bravery and resilience
that you guys have shown and
everyone we want to also just contribute
five thousand dollars to the stop
aapi hate organization an incredible
organization that promotes equality
and provides resources for the asian
american and pacific islander community
and um that is just you know a humble
thank you towards an organization that
is doing incredible things ming na
wen and kelly marie tran mulan
and raya the last dragon is in theaters
and on disney plus with premier access
on march 5th
it's incredible we loved it
and we love both of you